الآن هناك سؤال جاد حول
ما إذا كانت وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي تجعل
طفلك مصابًا بالاكتئاب ، وتلقي دراسة جديدة
الضوء على الرابط بين الصحة العقلية
واستخدام وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي هنا للتحدث
عن أحدث الأبحاث ، كبير المراسلين الطبيين لدينا
د.  سانجاي جوبتا سانجاي ،
أعتقد أنه ربما لا يكون مفاجأة
مثيرة للاهتمام
للغاية وأعتقد أنه مقنع للآباء في كل مكان.
من المحتمل أن تتأثر ولكن
ما الذي من المحتمل أن يحدث بالضبط
هنا لماذا يمكن ربط الاستخدام المتكرر لوسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
بأعراض الاكتئاب
وهناك نوع من ثلاثة أشياء
ركز عليها الباحثون حقًا يمكننا أن
نعرضها لك ولكن بشكل أساسي فكرة
أنك إذا  تتواجد على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي بشكل
متكرر وسأشرح ما
أعنيه بذلك في غضون ثانية من
المرجح أن تتعرض للتنمر عبر الإنترنت ،
ومن المرجح أن تعاني من قلة النوم
ونشاط بدني أقل ، وربما يكون
هذا واضحًا مرة أخرى ولكن هؤلاء  الأسباب الثلاثة
التي تجعلهم يركزون حقًا
على سبب حدوث أعراض الاكتئاب على
الأرجح في الفتيات
أكثر احتمالية للحدوث عند الفتيات ، يبدو
أن الأولاد غير واضحين.  rly معزول عن تلك
التأثيرات المحددة الآن لا
يعني ذلك أنه ليس لديهم أشياء
أخرى تؤثر على الأولاد ، ولكن فيما
يتعلق بقلة النوم ، فإن نشاطًا أقل
للتسلط عبر الإنترنت يؤثر حقًا على الفتيات الآن
نعلم أيضًا أن الفتيات أكثر عرضة
للإصابة بالاكتئاب  الأعراض بشكل عام بمجرد
أن يبدؤوا في سن المراهقة ، حتى
المراهقين والأولاد والبنات ، ترتفع
معدلات الاكتئاب المماثلة حقًا بعد المراهقات
، وهذا تأثير يستمر
حتى وقت
انقطاع الطمث تقريبًا ، لذا يمكنك وضع وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
فوق ذلك ويمكنك أن ترى  لماذا
لديك بعض هذه المشاكل التي تعرف
أنها تستحق الإشارة إليها أيضًا ، وهذا
فارق بسيط ولكن فارق بسيط ،
لم يكن بالضرورة مقدار
الوقت الذي تقضيه أمام الشاشة وأنت تحدق في
الشاشة ولكن كان تكرار
وقت الشاشة  وفكر فقط في أن هذا
هو عدد المرات التي تلتقط
فيها الجهاز
وتنظر إليه وتثبيته وتلتقطه وتنظر إليه وتضعه في
الأسفل لذلك هذا التردد  عليك
الانتباه ليس فقط إلى عدد
الساعات أو عدد الدقائق التي كنت
تبحث فيها عن وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي إرشادات سانجاي الشاملة ،
ما الذي نحتاجه لأخذ
هواتف أطفالنا بعيدًا لأنني لست متأكدًا من أن
هذه الفكرة ستنتهي بشكل جيد  من التردد مقابل الوقت الذي
ينتبه فيه جون إلى ذلك ، فهذا لا
يتعلق فقط ، أنت تعلم ،
لا يمكنك أن تظل على الشاشة لمدة
10 ساعات في اليوم ، إنه لا يجب
أن تلتقطها وتنظر إليها
مرارًا وتكرارًا ولكن ضع حدودًا يتم قياسها
كوالد ، فمن المحتمل أن تكون من
أهم الأشياء التي يمكنك القيام بها في
ظل الثقافة الحالية